Where I went into a restaurant the other
day in Toronto when this kid came up and
he shook my hand and he said,
I just want you to know that since I'd
been listening to you,
I've got three promotions at this
restaurant.
And I said,
well,
you know,
good work man,
like way to be.
And he said,
yeah,
well I started coming in on time and I'm
working really hard and I'm trying to
figure out how I can do a good job here
instead of being above the job,
you know,
I'll take this until I get something
better.
It's sort of beneath me.
It's like,
no,
probably not.
Actually.
It's not that easy to do most jobs.
It's actually hard to do most jobs
especially to do them well and it turns
out that the world is constituted if
society is set up well,
that if you do a good job,
invisible doors open in front of you.
Because people,
and I know this,
I've had lots of contact with businesses
and academic institutions and like the
people who run things competently are
often but not always interested.
Very interested in finding young people
that they can mentor and move forward.
It's actually one of the pleasures of
being competent than something.
And so if they see someone who's like
going that extra mile,
you know,
busy people have lots of opportunities
around them and they think,
oh,
I've got that opportunity,
I can't really do it,
but I can funnel it over to this kid
here.
Like let's see how he or she does it,
you know?
And so he said,
yeah,
you want to try this.
And the person says,
well,
I don't have time.
It's like,
well,
okay,
but the smart kid says,
yeah,
yes,
I'll do that.
And then the person with opportunities,
thanks watches and thinks,
okay,
well let's,
you know a bit,
see if the person does it.
And if they do it,
it's like,
hey,
here's four more opportunities that I
don't have time for is like bang.